you need to tell me what really happened
in here tonight now
[Music]
you've been all over the world
you could have a shop anywhere you like
and yet you're
here it doesn't terribly much matter
where i am
i have my shears
what else does a man need besides the
shears
this isn't art
this is a craft
you cannot make something good
until you understand the customer
do we let all of our customers keep
black boxes in back
if we only allowed angels to be
customers so we'd have no customers at
all
please says i don't want any trouble
i need you to listen carefully
there are a thousand blue boys out there
hunting for this and if they find it i
start shooting you follow
making matters worse there are a
thousand racket boys hunting for it too
and if they find it they start shooting
you follow you don't want to be involved
in whatever it is you do
you know exactly what it is that we do
whoa full house tonight huh
have you ever heard of the outfit the
outfit it's the network of every
big-time crew from santa monica to coney
island and tonight they sent us a
message
they're hiding something my friend
i'm gonna need that tape pal right now
why don't you try and take it gentlemen
it's gonna be a long night
sell him up
what i caught
so him up
you need to tell me what really happened
in here tonight
now
you've got five seconds to tell me what
happened open the trunk what open the
trunk and grab his arms or i'm hiding
two bodies five a number of things about
me that you don't know
four where's the tape for instance
i'm telling you the truth
you want to survive the night
you look them dead in the eyes and you
pretend you're one of them
you